hey guys it's been a little while since
I've done one of these walking talks so
first off couple updates number one
looks like our or a TV debut Ruben
report on Ora TV will be September night
they're building an awesome set I'm
really excited to show you guys the set
and everything that we're gonna be up to
a really cool number two it looks like
we are going to the Republican debate on
September 16th yeah if they let me in it
looks like we're going us we got some
cool stuff planned for that and now what
I wanted to talk about today was the
reaction to the videos that we did with
GAD said about a week and a half ago
right now I thought the response was
absolutely freakin incredible I think
there is an actual awakening going on in
the left this thing that I was talking
about with political correctness and you
know restraining free speech and all
this other [ __ ] and lying and
smearing people and all of this stuff
that has had me so frustrated for like
eight or ten months the reaction to it
in the YouTube comments looked right
down below in any of those videos and on
Twitter when I was getting on Facebook
people were emailing me and you got to
do a little research if you're gonna
find my email address and the reaction
was amazing people were saying this is
what I've been waiting for people that
are on the Left that are trying to stand
up for liberal principles for gay rights
and women's rights and economic equality
and all the things that liberals purport
to believe in were finally saying wow
somebody's actually saying this and on
top of everything else you know this
thing about atheists that somehow
atheists have been under attacked and as
I said in the interview with dad
atheists hold no power
atheists there's this whole idea that
these new a theists are so awful these
new atheists as my friend Kyle Koons he
said new atheists are just atheists that
are finally saying they're okay with
being atheists atheists have pretty much
been on the good side of everything and
believe in science a reason all that
stuff anyway my point in this is that
there is an awakening going on this is
what the Internet can do I can feel it
and I think you guys can feel it too and
that's why the response was so good so
let's keep saying the things we believe
it keeps standing up through
right stand up for reason and
rationality and those liberal principles
and Len have out and will start dragging
the people on the left that have gone
off the deep end how about we bring them
back to sanity I think we can do it